so I got a head-on collision at 60 miles
an hour and I walked away no injuries
but it was like my wake-up call but not
to stop drinking it was my wake-up call
that I needed to have these
conversations and that's what I was
avoiding when I was drinking it wasn't
the alcohols what were the things that
I'm avoiding that I'm using alcohol to
get away from and so the next day I had
the first conversation with the first
partner and it was horrible but the
moment I was done I was like I gotta
call the other guy and I called the
other one I was like this is how it is
and the thing is is I had this backstop
of my death
you almost just died because you
wouldn't have this conversation and so
then it just gave me this courage and
whatever the reaction was I was like I'd
rather be alive